[Music]  it's et social study a look at what the  stars are posting online hayden  Panettiere doing some mommy  troubleshooting on an airplane after her  daughter peed on the floor of the  bathroom pregnant Beyonce shared new  pics as she rocked this sexy mini dress  and thigh high boots ensemble to her  stepfather Richard Lawson 70th birthday  party Emily Ratajkowski hit the streets  of New York City in sexy lingerie  morning the new video is part of an ad  campaign for DKNY Nick Cannon is already  back on the grind after it was announced  Tyra Banks will replace him as host on  America's Got Talent  he shared a new pic from inside the  studio and the star studded wrinkle and  tie movie has wrapped filming director  Ava Duvernay  a Mindy Kaling and Reese Witherspoon  shared farewell photos from set  [Music]  you